hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game it's a game from
round 8 of the creation Grantchester
being played in Zagreb it's dinkley rand
versus magnus carlsen and well yesterday
Carlson defeated young information for
the first time in his life and now he
has the black pieces against the Tingler
and another player who he never defeated
in classical time format so far they've
played six or six or seven games and all
of them were drawn if you look at rapid
and blitz games then the Causton has
huge advantages he had that match
against the ding I believe somewhere
during the beginning of 2018 and he
really crushed him but as classical time
format goes it's all draws now I would
just like to mention before we check out
the game and it is a very nice game I
visited the Grand chest tour today
I can't I arrived there some hour and a
half before the the the game started I
thought maybe I'd get a chance maybe to
talk to some of the players or maybe
even get a photo with them or something
but everyone was arriving really late
for the game like a few minutes before
the game started and there really wasn't
time to to even ask any of the questions
you've written in the comments or
anything I will try to do that on
Saturday when I will visit once again
but I did get 10 out of 12 players to
sign the chess board that I brought with
me so here it is you can check it out
here are some of the signatures there
you have it if you're interested
pretty much everyone put a signature on
a light square only one person did it on
a dark square you can try and guess
whose signature it is on a dark Square
and yeah the ones I missed were Wesley
soul and 11 Wesley came really early but
he he didn't seem like he was interested
in in pretty much anything I think it
was just a very very focused on his game
I can see Carter good today and 11 was
really late for the game he was running
and I tried to hold a hold out to the
board and I was holding the pen you know
maybe if he wanted to put a signature on
it while running but he said that he was
so late that there was not enough time
even for that so I will
try to get the two signature signatures
on Saturday when I will visit the
Winchester once again and complete my my
board which will be very nice of course
I still haven't decided what I will do
with the board but after I have
completed what collecting signatures
then I will decide what to do with that
being said let's check out this very
nice game and also I met some very nice
subscribers today some of them wanted
you know to talk a little some of them
wanted to have some nice selfies and it
was just a very very exciting experience
for me so the game I think has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 of course
you all know where this is going nice to
f6 we have c4 e6 Knight f3 and we have
the Queens gambit declined the d5 you
know pretty much the same as it was a
hundred years ago during the capablanca
saga with g3 biding going for some sort
of a catalan set up with the strip the
East 7 Bishop - G - Magnus castles and
ding of course also castles with D
captors on c4 grabbing the gambit pawn
and now Queen to c2 preparing maybe to
recapture here
Magnus defense at b5 this is one of the
rare lines with it where it is actually
ok to defend the gambit at spawn a for
the flank attack you want to challenge
blacks decision to defend the gambit
pawn and now b4 and now Knight f2 d2
this is the main line you attack the
pawn and also open up a discovery
against the rope here so Magnus defends
it with Knight to d5 and now Knight
captures on c4 you win your pawn back
and the game continues with c5 for
Magnus now a nice flank attack to the
center d captures on c5 and there is one
game with this exact same line word
Bishop captures and see if I was played
but here Bishop to e6 by Magnus and
Magnus it came really prepared for this
game he really just blitzed out all of
his moves and ding was spending spending
a lot of time with Knight back the e3
offering a trade here and here you don't
want trade if you trade here we're just
gonna capture Bishop here and he's gonna
have a very strong pawn here the bishop
will be very nice here you will not be
able to save your rook so
with Knight to d7 Magnus prepares now
rook the c8 and now we have Knight
captures on d5 with each address on d5
and now you don't want to capture here
and give up your your c5 pawn even me
even at the price well of course you can
always go Roxy eight and you will pick
up the pawn later but Dean first goes c6
so already a very nice pass pawn and c6
with rook the c8 by Magnus first now of
course you cannot capture as the point
is pinned and now Bishop to f4 I think
you could have captured on d5 first but
the thing says there there's time for
that I'm just gonna play Bishop f4 take
away the e5 square from Magnus night so
he can go 95 and then I'm gonna decide
what to do with the pawn and as the
bishop is controlling c7 pawn to c7 is
the plan so nice the c5 now by Magnus
and now c7 wouldn't attack on the Queen
Queen to d7 and now Knight the d2 you
have to bring your other pieces into the
game as well and here you want to get
rid of the c7 point so how do you do it
and it's very interesting Magnus was
just blitzing out move here so it was uh
I I think all this was still preparation
for Magnus you could try and win it with
Bishop to d6 just trade the bishop here
that's defending it next move you're
gonna capture the problem with this move
is that it doesn't achieve what you want
it to achieve because of Bishop to h3
now we were threatening the world the
Queen and the rook if the Queen moves so
you want Queen captures Bishop and then
you get Bishop captures on d6 while you
are still guarding the c7 point
so what black could do is night to e6
but then you open up the Queen's defence
of the pawn again and now white can just
trade the ship captures F captures
Bishop captures here Queen captures and
after rook a to c1 your phone is nicely
protected so you will not be able to win
the pawn this way so Magnus played
believe it or not he played g5 and this
is I believe is still preparation as he
really did not spend any time here with
bishop here
f6 and now the bishop finally has to
leave the defense of the c7 pawn with
the shop to d4 and now comes Luke
captures on c7 finally
and things a very strong past c-pawn
with king queen to be won by ding
getting the Queen out of this diagonal
you also want to bring your rook into
the game and now Knight back to e6 and
you don't have a good way of saving or
Bishop if you just move it then this is
coming you're going to lose the bishop
this way
so just Knight the b3 and here Magnus
plays Bishop to c4 and that's up the c-4
is just a beautiful move because here
there's a lot of tension in the position
there's this tension the knight can
capture this ship the bishop can capture
night but all of the tension goes in
Carlson's favor and this is what you
always want to have interest when
there's tension on the board you want to
be the person creating the tension so
every move ding has to calculate okay I
might want to play h3 or I might want to
play rookie to c1 but he constantly have
to have to calculate okay root k c1 but
to then cross and can capture here a
cross and can capture here and well all
of these all of this goes into crossings
favors so a very nice move creating all
our attention with Knight but also with
the threat of course the bishop captures
night the Queen will have to leave the
defense of the bishop on d4 and you will
lose the bishop here so it's also also
comes with a threat with nice the a5
biding attacking the bishop here and now
Knight captures on d4 with queen cat
force on d4 and now King the g7 so what
do you do here here being played rook F
the c1 just bring that rook into the
game but cross and said that this he
didn't really agree with this move
because he thought that there was no
reason to give give up the e2 point sure
okay after d2 pony's captured you will
at some point to win back the d5 pawn
but constant thought that maybe ding
will play Bishop to f3 that it was a
nice move but okay ding went rook F to
c1 and cross and decided to capture it
with Bishop capture Sonny to rook
captures on c7 now Queen captures on c7
and now rook to e1
there's time to win this pawn here but
you also have this very nice threat the
rook captures Bishop and also there is
pressure against the bishop on e7 here
so for example if cousin captures night
here then you capture the
bishop and you also have a very nice
position threatening to capture on d5
threatening the bishop here
so first magnets gets rid of the bishop
on e7 first Bishop to c5 would an attack
on dings queen with Queen captures on b5
link now wins back the d5 pawn and now
rook to e8 Magnus not interested in any
trades especially not for the for the
Sicilian I 1085 he wants to keep his
bishop pair as if well if the pieces get
traded down then you will reach an end
game where Colson will have a bishop
prepare and of course with game on both
sides of the board but repair well will
in most cases have the advantage here
dink has to decide on what to do ding
here decides to trade Queens we have
Queen to b7
Magnus accepts we have Queen captures
Knight captures and now of course he
doesn't want to give up the bishop pair
so Bishop to f8 he just tucks it in for
later with bush of the c6 now and rook
the rook to e7 with f3 preparing King to
f2 to start bringing the King into the
game and now rush of the c4 with rook
captures on e7 Bishop captures on e7
King to f2 and now f5 and this is what
we've talked about now we have a well
the material on the board is equal both
players 5 points a3 and the King side
200 Quinn side and both wears well to
pieces but the difference is Magnus has
the bishop pair the game is on both
sides of the board so of course black
has the advantage as the knight it will
take a bit longer for night to reach
both sides of the board so normal
ding improves the reactivity of his skin
with pink the e3 and now Bishop the g8
now Magnus tux dis Bishop back for later
use as well King to d3 and now g4 now
here Magnus make sure that this h2 pawn
stays there for the rest of the game now
it's a backwards pawn it's a really weak
pawn and think we'll have to be very
careful about well defending it which
will will really be seen in the next
move here you want to play something
like F or even F capture some g4 maybe
but f4 probably better but here ding
play Knight to a5 he wants to get this
Knight back into the game but by playing
Knight to a5 here
allows halston a very important square
so feel free to pause the video here and
continue this endgame with black while I
enjoy and I sip of my water for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent and
game player and for those of you just
wanna enjoy the show the night when it
left to be seven it also left the
defense of the c5 square and it's a very
important square Magnus played Bishop to
c5 and now you see his plan he wants to
play Bishop g1 and well attack the h2
pawn as now it's a really weak point you
cannot advance it as and the previous
move Magnus also played the g4 so ding
decides to go after the f5 pawn and the
points on the kingside first-night c4
with Bishop to g1 Magnus continues with
this plant nice to e3 going after f5 and
now push up the e6 not allowing this
with F captures on g4 f captures on g4
and now King - E - so what do you play
here now with black of course not the
Bishop captures on h2 this would be a
mistake
you know Fischer took on h2 once and
that did not end well if you play Bishop
captures on h2 King f2 will trap the
bishop so next move you have to play
something you don't have time for h5
I've played five just King g2 and the
bishop is trap you don't have time for
h4 so first after King T - Magnus plays
h5 and now next move he will capture
here as he will have h4 ready
you should always prepare before you
capture on h2 with Bishop to d5 now
offering a trade but first Magnus
declines and Bishop to d7 with an attack
against the a4 pawn bishop back to b3
and only now when everything is ready
Bishop captures on h2 we have King to
have two preparing to trap the ship but
Magnus of course does not allow it with
h4 and now if you try Knight f1 to
somehow achieve something then H
captures and g3 will be perfectly fine
nice captures and well this Bishop can
now either capture the night or when the
knight moves just retreat and black will
enjoy his very nice extra pass pawn and
a protected one at that
so after h4 we have G captures on h4 and
now what do you play here
g3 wouldn't be all that great because
even though it seems nice you will not
be able to you know create any threats
with Bishop to c6 because ding made sure
of that the knight and the shop control
the d5 square so I have to remove the
King any Bush of the c6 will be met with
Bishop d5 and now even if you capture on
a4 it's not enough b3 you have to move
the bishop back and now you get a knight
f1 and you will eliminate these guys
here as they're on dark squares but will
be helpless to prevent that let's say a
five you're just gonna capture here
capture capture and it's two pawns each
light square Bishop each King each it's
a draw so after G captures on h4 first
prepared g4 first get the bishop out of
the way Bishop to e5 and only now Knight
the c4 ding attacks the bishop and now
first g3 check King to g1 and now Bishop
to it for controlling all of the squares
the knight can use to get back to the
Kings side with Bishop to d1 and now
Bishop the c6 grabbing hold of this
beautiful diagonal now the bishop and
the pond are controlling all of the
squares around the White King so you
will not be able to go up the board and
now as everything is you know very
nicely done on the King side Magnus is
now ready to take his King over to the
Queen side and wins win some material
there with the king we have b3 by dink
and now King to h6 with a 5 and now
comes the ship T 4 again if this bishop
now moves then even - of the c2 will be
enough to win material we've came to f1
pink the g7 now Magnus King is coming
all the way to the Queen side he decided
that the H point is not a threat with
King to g1 knockin scheme to have sex
King to f1 dink has no better moves as
other than to repeat them with King te
vi now comes a 5 sorry now comes h5
binding King to d5 and now a 6 so that
point is really far away but it will be
very hard to get rid of the a 7 point as
it is on a dark square thing only has a
light square bishop and it's well not
likely that this night can ever
and you can't go something like this
because of this point and you will not
be able to go something like this
because the bishop controls this
diagonal thus the the the c6 square so
in 2d for by Magnus with Bishop to g4
now and now King to c3 going after the
pawn here with Bishop to e6 now hoping
that Magnus will capture on b3 and then
you will have some nice discoveries but
just bishop the c2 of course you will
now capture with the bishop we have
Knight to a5 biding Bishop the c7
attacking the knight we're nice to b7
and only now the scores in play
Bishop to d3 this comes with check with
King to g1 by dink and it was in this
position after being played him to g1
that the players shook hands or so I
believe as there is pretty much nothing
more to do here yeah there are a lot of
ways you can win this you you can just
grab material but there's an even better
line as now all of the dings pieces are
so far away you can just play Bishop to
e4 and then you have a very nice forcing
sequence King to f1 for example I will
go G to check and after the King moves I
was taking to f2 now you get Bishop to
h2 and well they spawn now Queens and
there's no stopping that
so after this King did you one move
being resigned and a very nice victory
for Magnus Carlsen and it's the first
victory Magnus Carlsen ever achieved
against the Dengler and in classical
time format which is really insane as
it's also put the black piece the same
as against the young opponent in round 7
also with the black pieces the two
players he never defeated now he beat
them both in one tournament with the
black pieces which is just insane
I think now in lie braiding C is
somewhere close to his old parole the
highest ever rating
I think it's 2800 1082 is his record or
or close and he's very close to that now
so will he cross 2900 well if he
continues playing like this he like this
he most probably will but we'll just
have to wait and see we're not going to
show the standings as I'm gonna show
more games from this round and then
we're gonna
discuss the standings but s he was the
sole leader in the previous front and
now he won obviously he still the the
sole leader but we're gonna check out
the other results as well so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Tara Scarpia Avis Marrero
Victor Tonya's Jenni Orville and Michael
Castagna for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos ER think all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing this short coverage of this
very nice event
checking company or suggestions and of
course continue in the capablanca saga
so yeah thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
weekend
week sorry about that